the jurgen experience but drugs are
[ __ ] up in general man like i just
want to say
rest in peace to [ __ ] dmx that's a
sad one rest in [ __ ] paradise
man there's
did you see the video when they were
getting his body out of the hospital
nah that's
playing his music while they're driving
the car with his body out of the
hospital
i believe he's in white plains it's wild
that's crazy
just just rabbit fill in the streets i
wish i was able to tell him this story
i'm about to tell you because this is
[ __ ] real deal and it's like
he means so much to my family it's crazy
it sounds nuts not only did i grow up on
[ __ ] dma i love
dmx but
my wife was in [ __ ] labor for 18
[ __ ] hours and she had the doula
there
i told you they're on some spiritual
[ __ ] a [ __ ] peruvian
flute playing for 17
[ __ ] hours straight the peruvian
flute music i want to
you know the one that sounds like you
they came into my sixth grade class and
we made a [ __ ] flute
17 hours in the like the andes the ones
that
bro she starts freaking out i'm like
they're listening
we have an hour left or we're gonna have
to do a c-section or whatever and
she's no [ __ ] chance so
the [ __ ] peruvian flute music off and
i put [ __ ] dmx
on stop
drop that [ __ ] jumped out of her
i swear on everything it's on camera
it's on
film as soon as the peruvian flu
music stop dmx came on he [ __ ] heard
the dog
and he came out he just jumped out
i just amazed it it hurts my [ __ ]
heart that i was never able to tell him
that
oh man like man that's it's like
the crate it's the [ __ ] the doctor
was going nuts
because everyone was just [ __ ] sick
of that [ __ ] everywhere i wanted to jump
in tired right
i wanted to jump out of the window from
the music i was laid out on the floor
farting yeah i was [ __ ] because i had
like
i had hospital chips oh no hospital
but you know that shut down flushing
hospital for us
nice little area it was beautiful and so
it just changed the vibe of the room man
he [ __ ] popped right out on
everything like me it's on camera i
couldn't i
can't make that up
that would have been a good one but he
came out on the hit
stop drop shut him down open up shop
whoop he had some [ __ ] jams he had
some [ __ ]
nothing but he and what a voice just a
man what a voice he had
she's the dog [ __ ] drugs man
it's [ __ ] up it's taken up you think
about all the great artists that have
been
that have lost it lost their lives
because of drugs i mean it's
it's astonishing and you you go over it
all the musicians so many musicians but
artists are touched man
they're the ones that are the most
vulnerable to drugs they're touched
there's a lot of pressures and lots of
you itself yeah
it's you pretty much put it on yourself
when you become because you some people
don't know how to handle it
you know i've always been told that i'm
good at it like i'm good at being
who i am because i'm me yeah i
don't [ __ ] get nervous up there i
don't overthink i'm just
you know what i mean you got a good vibe
i'm just vibed out i'm not i'm not
worried about all these things everyone
like putting a [ __ ] chain on my neck
doesn't excite me
putting [ __ ] fancy cars don't excite
me i like having the things i like
but i'm [ __ ] i'm here i'm with
everybody i'm down here with being you
i'm [ __ ] happy being who i am man
it's just like
the most happy place i am it's very it's
very complicated for people also because
a lot of people are judging you and so
you get confused as to who you are
all day so that that's what happens with
a lot of famous folks
a lot of entertainers you get so many
voices
so if you're a person like dmx you
literally have millions of people
talking about you
good and bad and in both ways and
oh he's terrible he's the [ __ ] he's a
god
he's a bum he's a loser he's confused
he's my favorite it's confusing and
you just if you get the the this
you let these people influence who you
are
as a person if you let that in if you
take that in
and then you think about the pressures
of fame and maintaining fame
and one of the things about the rap
world in particular at least until
recently
is that like there was it was a very
short-lived
fame and there was something about guys
when they got to a certain age where
nobody wanted to hear from them anymore
you're right there was a lot of them
like that catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience